[Music]
in America's election headquarters
tonight primary day voters in seven
states are participating today in New
York former congressman and convicted
felon Michael Grimm tries to get hold of
his old congressional seat back in the
Republican Party there Democrats in two
states are selecting their fall nominees
for governor in Colorado candidates are
seeking to replace term limited Democrat
John Hickenlooper in Maryland former
n-double-a-cp president Ben Jealous is
one of the candidates looking to take on
incumbent Republican Larry Hogan in
November and then there's Utah where a
former presidential nominee is looking
at a new path to try to get to
Washington correspondent dan Springer is
in Provo tonight on the eve of the
Republican primary in Utah former
Massachusetts governor Mitt Romney was
still campaigning hard just outside
Provo six years after losing his bid for
the presidency Romney is hoping to take
a big step today toward another job in
Washington the US Senate and the latest
poll says he's a virtual shoo-in with a
42 point lead over his primary opponent
Mike Kennedy it's got Romney finally
agreeing to do national interviews where
the big question is how would a senator
Romney deal with President Trump if I
get to Washington I will work with him
and with the policies I think are right
I will oppose those things I think are
wrong for the country or for the state
and I'll speak my mind and issues of
conscience Romney says there would be no
return to the bomb-throwing days of 2016
when he was the face of the never Trump
movement Donald Trump is a phony a fraud
his promises are as worthless as a
degree from Trump University he was
begging for my endorsement I could have
said mitt drop to your knees he would
have dropped to his knees
but after Trump was elected both men
stood down and Romney even interviewed
to be Secretary of State while the
relationship thawed President Trump
seemed to take a swipe at Romney when he
strongly urged orrin hatch to stay in
the Senate but then in February he
surprised some by tweeting his
endorsement of Romney Romney says he's
not ready to endorse President Trump for
re-election but recently did predict
he'll win because of the economy the
Senate candidate also said Trump is no
role model
children but insists he will not try to
influence the white house to separate
branches my job is to try and get things
through the legislative branch that are
right for the country I'm not going to
try and manage the white house or how
the president interaction with others
that's that's up to him and his
administration and his team if Mitt
Romney wins tonight as is widely
expected they'll take on Democrat Jenny
Wilson who's a current city council
member in Salt Lake City and also the
daughter of a longtime mayor there just
to show you the challenge that lies
ahead for her when Romney ran for
president he won Utah Utah voters gave
him a 48 point victory here in Springer
in Provo dan thanks